the crisis were in the midst of right
now is what is fondly called the sixth
extinction on the planet we haven't seen
this fast or rapid a decline in biology
on the surface of the planet since about
fifty five million years ago when the
dinosaurs went extinct so this would be
the bees and things like that that we're
seeing is that part of that yeah so you
hear about bees you hear about you know
some of the loss of big animal life and
you hear of endangered species you hear
all this but what you don't hear about
is that we've actually killed 40% of
biology on the planet in the last 50
years we're almost halfway done wiping
out how all biology and so to have that
vast effect on all of biology and the
planet you start to realize that human
biology collapse that we've seen over
the last 20 years which is this chronic
disease explosion that we've had has to
be tied up in a bigger story than Oh
human health just sucks because we eat
McDonald's know if it was just a problem
with McDonald's then we would simply
have a human problem but we are wiping
out biology at every fractal from the
virus all the way up to macro life like
humans and large animals and ocean
animals and the rest and so to create
create that big of a shift in the
ability of biology to survive we must
have did something fundamental to the
fabric of biology what is that the
fabric of biology really comes down to a
catch term that's being thrown around
with a lot of misperceptions right now
which is the microbiome and the
microbiome is a description of an
environment or large ecosystem of tiny
bugs and so you've got viruses at the
bottom of that and as far our size and
kind of magnitude of spread so I
consider the viruses as the foundation
sitting on top of that you have the
fungi fungi have some five million
species and so we we think we get a
fancy grocery store we have four or five
species of mushroom something on there
and love mushrooms yeah
five million species oh well I haven't
even started yeah you got a ways to go
and you're coming away for the try mall
they're all fun no matter what kind
fun guys and say you got that whole
explosive you know fungal kingdom
sitting on top of this viral
intelligence and then sitting on that as
the parasites you have three hundred
thousand species of parasites and these
guys are kind of the first semblance of
multicellular organisms that would be
kind of you know predecessors to the
worms and you know the things you think
of as being the soil kind of architects
out there
but sitting on top of the parasite
kingdom then is the bacterial Kingdom
and we may have thirty or forty thousand
species of bacteria that are critical to
this biologic system so you got by
hearses fungi the parasites in the
bacteria created this large ecosystem
and then somewhere way way way out in
this almost pixel of life on Earth is
humanity and one way to look at the
scale of all of this is genetics
the human species is almost non-existent
genetically we have only twenty thousand
genes that's really pathetic cuz we
already knew by the time we figured out
we had twenty thousand genes we knew
that the fruit fly had thirteen thousand
genes and we knew that the flea had
thirty thousand genes so you fall
somewhere between a flea and a fruit fly
when it comes to genetic complexity and
that's very fascinating when you think
of the system that we build out of those
may your twenty thousand genes and so
you then compare that to let's say the
bacteria the bacteria with their 30,000
species have two million genes
that's that family then we go to the
parasites those three hundred thousand
species of pairs parasites have around 2
billion genes and then you go down to
the funded I and we're at five million
species of fungi and now you're looking
at 125 trillion genes and then you go
down to the viruses and we don't even
know how many species of viruses the
rough estimate that we currently have a
number of viruses on earth is ten to the
31 that's a one with 31 zeros after we
don't have a name for that number that's
to put that in perspective on the kind
of the galactic or universal scale
that's ten million times more than our
stars in the entire universe
and so ten to the 31 viruses and so
really I wake up every morning and just
so thankful that our senators of Disease
Control and figured out how
accented against three flu viruses every
year it's really ludicrous when we think
about our concept of vaccination like
we're trying to protect ourselves from
what we've got ten to the 31 viruses on
the planet that's so abundant with you
know quadrillions of genes that are
affecting our your 40,000 genes and then
we think of the fungi and we've got 125
trillion genes that are affecting our
genes and then we get the so you start
going down and you realize there's
absolutely no way that human life came
into existence without not only the
allowance of the microbiome letting us
be there but only by the provision of
the intelligence of the genetic genomic
of the microbiome of the world that we
exist
you